[MUSIC]
I want you to take a moment and
picture the person who
gave you your first big
career opportunity.
The person who took a chance on you to
do something you'd never done before.
Maybe before you were really ready.
Do you remember their name?
What they looked like?
What that meant for you?
So, I don't know who you're picturing,
what their name is or what they look like.
But I do know something
important Important about them.
In some meaningful way
they changed your life.
Now often when we talk about people
like this we call them mentors.
And we know that mentors
are people who give us advice,
share perspective, teach us new skills.
And we're told that early in our career we
should be constantly scanning our working
environment.
Always on the hunt for that next mentor.
But of everyone who mentors you
has the power to help you move up.
To get to that next level to advocate for
you when it really counts.
We need a different word for that.
We'll call that sponsorship.
And while I believe that mentors matter,
we need sponsors to be really successful.
So, what is sponsorship?
A sponsor sees a potential in you.
They give you access to
the kinds of experiences and
relationships that they already have, that
you may not be able to find on your own.
And finally, they'll put their own
reputation on the line to advocate for
your commotion.
Whether it's to greater responsibility or
visibility.
Now my guess is that each of you could
probably tell me right now specifically
what your sponsor did for you.
But, sponsorship as a skill
set that is generalizable.
It matters in every profession.
So to picture this, I want you to
picture a professional hero of mine.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yoda.
Now, I loved Star Wars as a kid and
I love it even more now because Yoda,
it turns out, is one of the greatest
sponsors of all time, and here's why.
When we first meet him,
Luke Skywalker looks a lot more like
a farm hand then a Jedi Master, but
Yoda sees through that to the potential
in him and decides to sponsor him.
Next, he creates opportunities for
Luke to learn the kinds of skills
he'll need to be successful as a Jedi.
Now what's important about this,
is that he's not just giving Luke advise.
He's giving him access to the kinds of
experiences that Luke wouldn't have
known how to find on his own.
And finally, and if you haven't already
been taking this metaphor with a grain of
salt you could start now,
Yoda's dying act is to promote Luke.
He makes him the last of the living Jedi,
and
that former farm hand goes
on to save the Galaxy.
So, at this point,
you might think that this talk is about
the importance of finding your Yoda.
Someone to advocate for you and
help you achieve great things.
But actually this is a talk about
the importance of being a Yoda and
how to discover that greatness in others,
and there's three
important reasons to do so.
First, and this might be obvious, but
sponsorship is a way to have a measurable
impact on somebody else's life.
Think back to the person you
pictured at the beginning.
You know what a powerful impact
that sponsorship had for you.
But what if you had never met that person?
Or, what if you had, but they just hadn't
chosen you to take that chance on?
Where would you be now?
That gap between what could have been and
what is is tangible to you.
Although, perhaps hard to
measure except looking back.
So if you want to change lives,
sponsorship is a way to fill that gap for
someone else.
Now, second, and
this is perhaps less intuitive.
Sponsorship turns out to be good for
the sponsor.
Imagine having a bench
of people who feel about
you the way you feel about
the person you pictured.
What could you get done?
And this isn't fluffy stuff.
A delight study found that 70% of people
who self identify as sponsors reported
faster progression in their own careers,
and this makes sense, right?
Because while earlier in our
careers we're rewarded for
being strong individual producers.
There comes a time when the things we're
asked to achieve, we can't do on our own.
And that's when having a bench counts.
And there's something powerful about
filling that bench with people who
are early in their own careers.
There is a saying in Silicon Valley that
there's two kinds of investors here.
People who invested in the Facebook early,
and people who didn't but wish they did.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now I can't tell you how to
invest your money.
But when you invest in people early
the return is a network that's
not just broader but deeper.
And that social network is a competitive
advantage as a leader who wants to get
big things done.
So, sponsorship.
It's good for others and
it's good for you.
But there's a third reason I
want you to consider this.
And that's because sponsorship
is a powerful tool for
changing organizations
from the inside out.
No matter what stage you
are at in your own career.
And here's why.
We know that organizations with diverse
teams have better business outcomes.
And when I look at the world outside
of our classrooms, I see lots of
organizations that have figured out how
to hire fairly diverse pools of talent,
at least at the entry levels.
But despite knowing this,
leadership remains looking
stubbornly like it did 30 years ago.
This says to me that
there's something broken
in how we're moving people
through organization.
And that, it looks less like a ladder than
like a climbing wall with the ropes and
carabiners are only handed
down to some people.
I believe that in many ways,
it comes down to who is getting sponsored.
Research shows that we're more likely
to spend time with, communicate with,
trust, and by extension sponsor,
people who are similar to us.
It's literally human nature.
But in a world where 80% of senior
leaders, and 97% of CEO's are men.
It's perhaps not surprising that
sponsorship can end up looking,
in some ways, a self-replicating system.
And again, people liking people who are
like them doesn't make them bad people,
just human.
But what it says is that if we truly
want to create diverse organizations We
have to do and feels a natural.
And be intentional.
About looking for potential and
people who don't look like us.
No matter who are or what you look like.
I hope the bunch of people you build,
looks just like this and more like this.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
I hope that by being explicit about
what sponsorship is, what it's done for
you and me, and
how we can step into that role ourselves,
we could be the ones to break that self
replicating And it's not hard to do.
First, we can start now.
So many of us picture our sponsors to be
older and wiser that you don't have to
wait until you're a shriveled,
green 900 year old to do this.
>> [LAUGHS]
>> No matter where you are, there
are Luke Skywalkers behind you wanting
to go to your academic institution.
Work for your company or
move up into your current role.
We can be intentional about looking for
potential in people who
do not look like us.
We can be thoughtful, about giving those
people access to the experiences and
relationships we already have, that they
may not know how to find on their own.
And finally, we can be strategic.
About advocating for their promotion,
so that they can benefit from our own
attempts to make it up that climbing wall.
To change the world that we inherit,
we need not just more sponsorship,
but better sponsorship.
And we need it to start now,
not in another decade.
So I hope that this talk could
be a kind of playbook, for
us to go out into the world and
be intentional about sponsoring.
And I hope you do so,
because it's a powerful way to have
an impact on somebody else's life.
And I hope you do so
because it's an investment in yourself and
your ability to get big things done.
And I hope you do so
because it's a powerful tool for
changing organizations
from the inside out.
But most of all, I hope you do so
because our legacies are not
just the businesses and
bank accounts we leave behind.
But rather,
the people whose lives we helped to build.
You know what it's like to have found
your Yoda So go out and find your look.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]